they say like I thought was my kid I
would never let them have an adoption
those people that say that they're wrong
because they would give their children
up for adoption if they thought they
would have a better life my name is
Johanna I am a proud birth parent this
is something that I'm very passionate
about and getting to share my story and
listen to other people's stories it's a
very powerful thing
I'm Scott Cardinal I am an adoptive
parent I'm also a birth father of a boy
that was adopted when I was about 17 18
years old I was pregnant when I was 15
and choosing to put up your child for
adoption it's traumatic and it's
something I deal with every day
so I'm Jackie I was adopted at 20 hours
old it's with relationships and even my
adoptive family they don't really like
bringing it up my name is Andrea I was
adopted as an infant I just think
there's not enough people talking about
it and people's stories are some of the
best advice that you can give
hi I'm Scott I'm an actor and I'm 57 hi
I'm Sierra I'm 22 years old and I'm a
stay-at-home mom and a youtuber I'm
Joanna
I'm 34 i am i work from home mom and I
am also a birth parent hi I'm Jackie I'm
23 years old I work with LAUSD and I was
adopted at 20 hours old hi I'm Andrea
I'm a fashion designer here in LA and I
was adopted from Korea at six months can
I get my birth parents to the left and
my adoptees to the right my life is
better because of adoption
culture was a lot different back then in
Korea if I stayed in Korea I wouldn't
have had any opportunities like I do
here my life would definitely be better
or is better off because of it for me I
would say yeah my life is a lot better
my biological mom she had you know seven
other children to look after and the
reason she had to do what she had to do
is you know times were hard so I was
able to be blessed with all the
opportunities I got you know when I was
a birth parent and I put my son up for
adoption I couldn't have given him the
life that his parents gave him and I
think he was better taken care of than I
could do and then when I adopted it it
changed my life because you know we have
a beautiful daughter
it really helped bring it full circle
and I was able to repay something that
someone else helped my son way so the
answer is yes and no at the time I was
15 I was with the guy who took advantage
of me all I knew is I I wasn't making
any money yet at the time I thought it
was the best decision but sometimes um
sometimes I wish she was with me
you know do what is that the worst
mistake I ever made you know you just
you don't know so I think only um only
time will tell
I'd you know completely identify with
that at the time it was kind of my only
choice I would say yeah I wasn't ready
to be a parent now my child is turns 18
actually next week and has had so many
issues with the adoptive parents not
accepting him because he's transgender
Oh knowing that I could have been the
parent that he needed adoption hasn't
made my life better it's given me a
little turmoil
birth parents should try to stay in
touch oh I feel like it is important for
said child to understand where it is
that they come from and not feel that
you know they were just abandoned I was
a little torn because I do think that
birth parents should do their best to be
in touch you know if the child is ready
you know but a lot of times there's
trauma that people don't really think
when it comes to birth parents and what
they're dealing with you need to make
sure that you are in the right headspace
before you reach out you may need to
join you need to be the best person that
you can be if you're going to be
involved in their life beyond that just
being in touch so that if you develop a
physical ailments gonna be passed on to
genetically you want your kids to know
those things but I think that the the
evidence is pretty clear that having an
opener
adoption is better than closed yeah I
think for me it was better growing up
having closed because I really it it
made me really adapt into my
surroundings and not always like if I
was a teenager had an open adoption I I
would have you know got mad at my
parents and now I've come full circle
and and I think it helped me more being
closed I have a hard time connecting
with my blood family or child
actually yeah I guess you could say I
was blessed with the family I had
because they purr I guess a little bit
wealthier with money and my siblings
weren't as you know so sometimes it is
hard to relate to them of you know how
different our childhoods were well with
me the reason why I was so like it was
so hard for me to decide it's not that
it's hard connecting with my child is
that I can't I cannot physically handle
that connection and not having him with
me yeah and I have a very hard time
connecting with my my blood son my birth
son because we're so different and a lot
of painful things have happened between
us we really don't have much of a
relationship anymore because of that
[Music]
when I think about my blood family I
mean we're all so different but my blood
child my teenager like we're on the same
wavelength you know ever since I got to
be able to start seeing him when he was
about six years old he came up to me
poked me in the belly and said God put
me in your tummy because my mommy
couldn't have me in hers and I just
cried and he just gave me the biggest
hug and that ever since then we just had
this connection and we can talk about
anything and that's the best thing I
could ask for you don't always get that
I just don't have a birth parent to
connect to you know I've tried searching
for her but she didn't want to be found
on the birth papers and there was no
record of my birth father so I didn't
want to ruin her life if she's trying to
make a new life for herself it's it's
even more taboo in Korea when I was 17
through my adoption agency I went to
Korea and got to see my birth
hometown the hospital I was born in so I
got closure that way I'm talking to
other adoptees yeah I don't need to keep
worrying about the past it's like I'm
just focusing really on the parents I do
have and the connections and make out of
it and that's what helps me heal I have
felt guilt and shame surrounding
adoption when I found out I was pregnant
my family had told me if I have an
abortion I will go to hell if I have the
adoption they will cut me out of the
family when I went into labor they would
come into you know the room while I was
in labor and they say like I can't
believe you're doing this
I thought wasn't my kid I would never
let them have an adoption I can tell you
something else those people that say
that they're wrong because they would
give their children up for adoption if
they thought that we have a better life
yes and about 95 percent of those people
there they're not mothers they're not
parents or anything so being a mother
now it's just I understand you know
where my birth mom came from she wanted
what's best for me period point blank
and I don't resent her for that at all
and I never will they say well you were
you know you might have been given up
but you were adopted and you should have
this full life like there's no problems
you're with sharing - laughs he's we
were chosen not just given up but I
didn't realize until recently that how
the shame and guilt formed of like why
am I depressed well why do I still have
turmoil like I should be thankful for
everything but being trans Rachel it's
like I grew up in Minnesota so it's very
like homogeneous like very white culture
I wasn't alone but subconsciously alone
in my own being you don't have that
foundation of where you come from and
your bloodline in history I had no one
to talk to
so it was constantly me fighting with
myself of
the with the [ __ ] licking with the guilt
and shame that came up in every
situation that where I felt emotionally
insecure adoptive and birth parents
should be seen as equal
I'm only coming because I don't think I
can agree or disagree I'm gonna listen
to what everybody has to say you know
birth parent or adoptive parent it takes
really a strong will from someone to one
give your child up for adoption but also
open your home to a child that isn't
yours but you're willing to give them
the home that they deserve well but also
you know don't get the idea that you
know when an adoptive parents about a
kid they're doing it out of the goodness
of their heart we need you we needed you
to make our family and that's it's not
like you know we're some sort of
superheroes you guys are our superheroes
yeah oh it's true we need you yeah and
our lives wouldn't be complete without
you yeah and I think the child at the
end of the day that's when they talk
about the Triad it's child's on top it's
all about what's best for them so even
if you aren't there to parent them it's
there always in your mind and you're
always worried about them how are they
doing what's their home life like you
know what how are they feeling are they
gonna lose a tooth soon you know like
these little things that that you think
about you may not know your birth mom
but the fact you're able to sympathize
with her like because I'm always afraid
that my son's gonna grow up and hate me
no and he might I don't know I wouldn't
through a time of hating you know they
say it's that inner turmoil it's like
you're depressed before you can even
internalize feelings because it's that
subconscious trauma
and my parents they have the video of me
coming off the plane and like to see
them so excited and I don't know how I
got grace to these parents but like I
feel like they were supposed to be and I
can talk to them openly
you know I've been praying and asking
God to us show me a sign with the
adopted journey and honestly I feel like
you guys you taught me a lot today
and I'm really thankful for that
likewise it's like therapy